Se abrieron las puertas de mar a Lago y
salió la comitiva de seguridad de Donald
Trump en el camino al aeropuerto de Palm
Beach en torno a 200 simpatizantes del
ex presidente y rumbo a Nueva York
en donde más prensa que simpatizantes lo
esperaron frente a la torre trampa
apoyamos a este hombre amamos al
presidente Trump el verdadero presidente
Trump deberá compadecer el martes ante
un juzgado por los presuntos pagos a la
actriz porno stormy Daniels durante la
campaña de 2016 con ello se habría
buscado el silencio de Daniels por una
relación extramatrimonial 10 años antes
un juez que le dirá Cuáles son los
cargos en su contra le preguntará Cómo
se declarará Y en este caso no habrá
fianza Entonces liberará al expresidente
Bajo su propia responsabilidad
también se le tomarán sus huellas una
caza de brujas según sus seguidores
está siendo perseguido políticamente En
mi opinión porque Alvin brack nunca
acusa a los verdaderos criminales la
acusación sin embargo no es por el acto
de pagar por silencio algo que no está
tipificado como delito la ilegalidad
vendría de un presunto registro ilegal
de Los 130.000 dólares pagados como un a
su abogado Michael cohen
like
Parece que habrá al menos algún fraude
financiero de campaña y que elevaría el
caso de un delito menor a un delito
grave y eso es relativamente grave pero
es la clase de delito grave más baja en
el estado de Nueva York
por el momento la gran manzana refuerza
la seguridad ante un evento tan
relevante para el futuro político del
país se esperan manifestaciones de los
simpatizantes de Trump quien ve como su
popularidad vuelva a aumentar por este
caso